Jason Blum and James Wan's new horror flick
"M3GAN" has become the "Citizen Kane" of killer
doll movies, notching an unexpectedly high
critics rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
But what are moviegoers and everyday people
actually saying about the film?
Directed by Gerard Johnstone, "M3GAN" focuses
on a toy company roboticist named Gemma who
creates a life-like doll that runs on artificial
intelligence.
According to the Rotten Tomatoes synopsis,
If that didn't sound creepy enough, Gemma
actually decides to give her own 8-year-old
niece the first M3GAN prototype, leading to
some horrific consequences.
"You should probably run."
Rotten Tomatoes' critical consensus describes
"M3GAN" as being "unapologetically silly and
all the more entertaining for it," calling
it a "rare horror-comedy that delivers chuckles
as effortlessly as chills."
"It sounds like you're fighting."
"We're not fighting!"
But everyone knows critics and moviegoers
can often have different opinions when it
comes to mainstream films.
However, it seems that "M3GAN" is also a hit
among general moviegoers, with the film being
praised far and wide on social media.
One Twitter user said,
Another user tweeted,
One user even declared, "M3GAN is a perfect
movie," while another singled out the music,
posting,
Overall, it seems that most people who come
out of "M3GAN" are actually loving the horror
flick, and not holding back their love for
it.
The general consensus is that it's a movie
that doesn't take itself too seriously, and
in similar fashion, neither should audiences
— which is exactly what's happening.
Going into "M3GAN," most people seem to understand
that this isn't some dramatic character study.
As one Twitter user puts it,
"Oh really?"
A "campy good time" is a common refrain.
One Redditor posted,
Another of the site's users wrote,
When making "M3GAN," director Gerard Johnstone
made sure to create a movie that was both
self-aware and campy, but also enjoyable and
actually good at the same time.
He told Collider in a January 3 interview,
So Johnstone tried to find a happy medium,
reasoning,